los franceses ya no pueden disfrutar de
las terrazas de los cafés sin su pase
sanitario como estas varios lugares
comenzaron a requerir este lunes el
certificado digital
esta mañana colocamos nuevos carteles en
cordones para proteger la terraza para
que podamos controlar a las personas
antes de que entren
así que si este protocolo por los
adoquines de la capital
ahora patrullas policiales controlan qué
bares restaurantes y otros lugares
culturales apliquen la regulación un
poco para este método no podremos
controlar todas las terrazas pero
efectivamente al hacer controles
aleatorios que se harán a diario y que
permitirán esperamos pasar el mensaje
con firmeza es el mensaje ahora déjame
te queremos convencer al mayor número de
personas para que vayan a adornarse y
que así puedan tener un pase sanitario
valiente
a pesar de que muchos franceses han
aceptado la medida otros la siguen
tirando de absurdos con séptima pnv a
cuestas yo realmente no sé qué es esto
estamos sentados en una mesa al aire
libre
no somos dos no hay nadie alrededor es
el absurdistán numérico numérico el pase
también entró en vigor para los viajes
en trenes de larga distancia y en
trayectos interurbanos pondremos en
marcha controles masivos controles que
se realizan en el andén del tren como
pueden ver aquí en la estación de lyon
con una gran cantidad de personal
movilizado en los andenes también habrá
controles dentro de los trenes
aun cuando la medida desembocó en
multitudinarias manifestaciones todos
los franceses sin excepción deberán
hacerlo parte de su nueva realidad